جرح غائر احدثه زلزال تركيا وسوريا وكان
من المتوقع ان يقرب بين الاتراك والسوريين
القاتنين في تركيا الا ان صحيفه وولد
الامريكيه اشارت الى ان هناك تصاعد بمشاعر
العدائيه بين السوريين او تجاههم في جنوب
تركيا في اعقاب الزلزال الاستياء التركي
ينطلق من اتهام بعض الاتراك للاجئين
السوريين في البلاد بسرقه المتاجر
والمنازل المتهدمه وجار تداول شعارات على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي منها لا نريد
السوريين وايضا لم تعودوا محل ترحيب كما
انتشرت بعض عروض المساعده في الفضاء
الالكتروني التي تعرض مساعده منكوبي
الزلزال شريطه ان يكونوا سوريين او يكون
اتراك فعليا مواطنون سوريون قالوا انهم
باتوا لا ماوى لهم بسبب هذا الزلزال بعدما
طردوا من مخيمات الطوارئ وواجهوا اهانات
عن
الى ان بعض السوريين الذين يعيشون دون
اوراق رسميه في تركيا يخشون الوصول الى
السلطات طلبا للمساعده خوفا من تعرضهم
للترحيل وتستضيف تركيا ما يقرب من اربعه
ملايين لاجئ سوري يتركز كثير منهم في جنوب
البلاد قرب الحدود السوريه ورغم ان
الاستياء من السوريين ليس امرا جديدا غير
ان الزلزال ادى الى تفاقم هذا التوتر كما
كانت التوقعات تشير الى انه ملف اللاجئين
في السوريين سيكون موضوعا رئيسيا في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه هذا
العام
[موسيقى]
اذا اثار الزلزال استياء بعض الاتراك تجاه
اللاجئين السوريين في البلاد الذين يتم
تحميلهم دون دليل مسؤوليه عمليات النهب
وسط الدمار والفوضى وافاد سكان وعمال
اغاثه بوقوع عمليات نهب وتوقف عدد من فرق
الاغاثه الاجنبيه عن العمل لفتره وجيزه
بسبب تدهور الوضع الامني بينما يكافح سكان
ولايه هاتاي جنوب شرق تركيا على الحدود مع
سوريا من اجل البقاء على قيد الحياه بعد
الزلزال اصبح السكان السوريون الذين
يعيشون هناك منذ اكثر من عقد هدفا للغضب
المتزايد السكان محرومون من الماوى
والكهرباء والمياه بينما يواجه السكان
سكان المدينه المنكوبه نهبا متزايدا في
وقت تحاول فيه القوات الخاصه والجيش في
جميع انحاء الولايه منعه
من عائله ما في ضوء ولا في شيء
والبرد ايش بدنا نسوي
لازم نحتاج لكل شيء لاننا لم ناخذ شيئا من
منازلنا التي دمرت بالكامل
الناس هنا يعتنون بالسوريين منذ عشر سنوات
لكن نصف السوريين خانوا اهالي انطاكيا
عندما غادروا المدينه غادروها وهم يسرقون
لا اقول انهم جميعا سيئون ولن اقول ذلك
يعاني بالفعل بغض النظر عنهويتهم واضافه
التوتر هنا وفي وسائل الاعلام سيؤدي الى
انفجار الغضب في المجتمع وتفاقم الوضع